Courtney Cox is finally weighing in on
her unexpected mention in Prince Harry's
bombshell Memoir spare specifically his
claim that he did mushrooms at her house
I was so surprised let me get you up to
speed in his book which dropped in
January the Duke of Sussex and
self-proclaimed friends fanatic recalls
crashing at Court's house during a trip
to La he says he found a huge box of
Black Diamond mushroom chocolates in the
fridge during a party at the actress's
home Harry says he and a friend grabbed
a few and washed them down with tequila
before detailing the bizarre side
effects of his drug-induced trip
including a trash can transforming into
a head in the bathroom quote I stepped
on the pedal and the head opened its
mouth a huge open grin I laughed wow
well now Courtney is breaking her
Silence about all that in an interview
with variety published on Monday
admitting he did stay at her house for
two or three days and adding he's a
really nice person Court says she hasn't
read his book yet but has heard it's
really entertaining I'm really excited
as for the prince's psychedelic story
Court insists she knows nothing about it
quote I'm not saying there were
mushrooms I definitely wasn't passing
them out because I would know about that
yeah so the mystery of the mushrooms
remains but one thing that's for sure
Courtney just keeps getting better with
age she tells variety that she's the
happiest she's ever been and there's a
lot of things she enjoys about getting
older like taking more chances with her
career directing acting and producing
there's just something about the
confidence of time of doing something so
long I probably love it more now than I
ever have with over three decades of
acclaimed work courts earned the honor
of a star on the Hollywood Walk of Fame
and new generations continue to fall in
love with her thanks to her clever
social media content like the time she
recreated the routine from friends with
the help of Ed Sheeran
[Music]
or how about that time she slayed the
sitcoms theme song on the piano
[Music]
but honestly nothing was more legendary
than when Court put a turkey on her head
to recreate this famous scene
those were the days for sure it was just
the best opportunity on the best show
and I was I was really lucky to be a
part and become friends and work with
all of those incredible people so
whether she's letting Prince Harry crash
at her pad showing off her acting and
producing chops or making us laugh on
social media Courtney is everyone's
favorite friend
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you